the establishment is in a meltdown over
the previous summit the g7 summit
President Trump's criticism of allies
over trade is unprecedented they scream
he's undermining something that they
call the rules-based international order
that apparently is all you need to say
end of discussion
notice the only thing the foreign policy
establishment cares about is style they
don't engage with the substance at all
these pompous pearl clutches of the
international elite the world leaders
with their bland communicates crafted by
time serving diplomats who think they
really run the show the arrogant and
unaccountable bureaucrats running
outfits like the EU and the IMF who are
basically just Stooges for big business
the self-regarding after-dinner
pontificate errs that the Washington
think tank circuit who glides smoothly
over the real world catastrophes
unleashed by their ideology without ever
acknowledging the slightest mistake and
of course the gullible commentators and
journalists who unthinkingly lap up all
this self-serving elitist rubbish while
presenting themselves as fearless
pursuers of the truth when you see these
people rounding on President Trump for
daring to question their world view the
pithy phrase of Nassim Taleb comes to
mind I why I intellectual yet idiot what
is this rules-based international order
that the ioy eyes are so attached to
here in America and across the Western
world the rules-based international
order made the rich richer and working
people poorer as incomes went down and
jobs went away it ripped apart the
social fabric helping create the twin
disasters of family breakdown and
community disintegration an undermined
faith in government and democracy as
citizens saw that it didn't matter who
they voted for in actual elections that
end up with the same elite serving
policies regardless the trade rules of
the International order are tilted
against America allowing rampant
protectionism by the EU and epic abuse
by China the rule-based international
order didn't stop Russia invading
Ukraine it didn't stop Iran
destabilizing the Middle East it didn't
stop the rise of al-qaeda and Isis it
didn't stop China getting to the brink
of
world domination oh and it didn't stop
North Korea from having nuclear weapons
although to the bitter disappointment of
the sneering elites Donald Trump just
might when I worked as an advisor in 10
Downing Street I wanted Prime Minister
David Cameron to cancel the g8 summit
when it was Britain's turn to host it so
I loved seeing President Trump called
time on 50 years of elitist failure yes
you can call it unprecedented but doing
things that are unprecedented is the
very definition of Donald Trump's
mandates he was elected to change things
not keep them the same the elitists
hate-filled hysteria shows their true
colors
they love the old order because they and
their rich friends benefit from it how
disgraceful that they howl in protest
when President Trump tries to put
working people first tell me what you
think of the g7 aletan meltdown next rev
fnc and that steve hilton x